one of the two civilian victims is
opening up about what about her
experiences and what happened to her the
chair of that evening
Mia Taylor was also singing the Chiefs
praises she was shot in the leg and then
she rushed to shield her teenage son
from the gunfire
I spoke to Mia and her husband and their
four sons about that horrible moment
last night and where they go from here
what did that feel like being shot what
does that feel like I want to say like
someone just jabbed you wouldn't me too
it's a real sharp thing but you knew it
was a bullet well yeah you knew that
yeah because it was hot and caused you
to fall I didn't fall but I kind of
buckled and I was I got hit and I'm kind
of limping and that's when Andrew turns
around and he's look at him to see where
I am and starts to grab at me and I'm
already shot so I grab him is at that
point you're worried now about
protecting Andrew absolutely so I turn
around and look for my mom and I look
for my mom she simultaneously grabs me
and basically tackles me and to a curb
in a car and she lays right on top to me
all that was exposed was my head you
said you were scared you just did what I
basically sat there and held my breath I
didn't know what was going on I was
based I was shocked I never thought
something like this would have ever
happened to me my mom and my brothers it
felt like a couple of minutes they could
have been less and just a barrage of
police officers came up and one of them
asked me is anybody hit I I was thinking
yes but in a real low tone and shaking
my head because you didn't want Andrew
to know I did not want my son to know
that I was shot and then was that the
officer who you saw get shot the one
that I saw was actually against the wall
I saw him get shot right in front of you
yes ma'am and when you saw that what did
you think I'm just praying I did not
stop praying that night the police put
themselves in harm's way
yeah and saved you you said they did
absolutely and I am forever indebted
there was no color there there was
safety there was a there was action and
I can't thank him enough
mm-hmm what was your expectation in
going to the protest I wanted my kids to
see maybe experience something to what
their grandparents had experienced at
one point in time marching for that
March might work
yeah I'm saying yes that it can work cuz
I hear a lot of people saying well what
is marching gonna do well they did a lot
why can't he do it again so when your
wife said I'm going and I'm taking
taking our sons you were fine I had no
problem with it I appreciated her for
doing it what why did you appreciate her
doing it justice or sometimes that we
can get it give unify Joanne why did you
want to go I wanted to go to actually to
be in the movement the movement I wanted
to march I wanted to be able to make
history and tell my kids oh whoa
when this was going down this happened I
was there
your mom tells me that you want to be a
police officer is really Eastern why cuz
I just want to try to make this world a
better place and hopefully as I get
older the world will change
it'll be a safer environment for black
people and even all races truthfully
what do you hope Andrew that we all
learn from this truly I hope that
everyone wears to rights our two wrongs
don't make a right
it's a conversation and people have to
have those conversations it's hard
conversations like my mom said I have a
large amount of white friends and it's
really authentically hard to have those
conversations with your friends with
your friends with even with your friends
and let alone have them with strangers
somebody who said well now the message
is getting lost do you feel that I think
so
never to my understanding have I ever
felt like only black lives matter we
want to feel safe when we send our sons
their daughters out of our homes we want
we want we want to feel safe when
they're out and and know that they're
being protected now Mia Taylor will be
in a wheelchair for a few more weeks as
she recuperates from the wounds that she
suffered in her leg she told us that
while she's still hurt and she's very
frustrated by the shooting it won't stop
her from participating in more rallies
with her children I have to say guys I
was very impressed with the Taylor
family all of the kids the mom and the
dad the thing they wanted to just most
is that the black lives matter didn't
have anything to do with the shooting
this was just totally the shooter was
someone that had nothing to do with the
cause and it sort of tainted the
movement that they were all trying to
say that before that shooting that it
was a very peaceful protest that the
protesters and the police officers were
actually hugging each other and and
congratulating each other for bringing
the message to the public so well it's
been tainted they said that they are not
deterred and the dad in particular said
do not judge a book by its cover until
you read the book I thought that was
very good advice I didn't see any color
know exactly that you know one thing
Charlie you'll like this she said I said
Mia they're calling you a hero mom she
goes I am NOT a hero I am just a mom and
I'm just a wife I always hear you say
Charlie when heroes never want to say
that they're heroes but her kids say our
mom is a hero back to you guys really
nice family indeed gale thank you so
much